president biden is trying to bolster his
climate change credentials with
upset progressives tonight this comes as
some from his own base are calling the
president
a coward today president biden tried to
equate global warming with the western
heat wave
white house correspondent peter ducey
has details
the president says it's simple i know
you all know it i hope your constituents
know there is
climate change
but because meaningful climate action
was cut out of that bipartisan
infrastructure framework
activists are furious marching as close
to the white house as they could
with signs reading quote biden you
coward fight for us sometimes folks need
a little reminder of the communities
that took them to the dance right
over here we're inviting the white house
to advance
message received in the west wing i
would say first that
we respect the right of anyone to
peacefully protest
that's an american right a fundamental
right i will say that the president
believes that
what's in the infrastructure package is
an important down payment
on addressing what he sees as a crisis
in our climate
on a zoom call with western governors
administration officials tried to
highlight a heightened risk of wildfires
this season
with the vice president drawing upon her
experience in paradise california
the only thing standing in that
community were the chimneys
which looked in that scene like
tombstones
the collapsed condo in florida could
have been caused by climate change too
according to the energy secretary
jennifer granholm we do know
that the seas are rising i mean we know
that we're losing
inches and inches of beaches that
speculation is not welcomed by some
lawmakers in florida to come out and to
play your politics and to talk about
climate change and sea level rise it's
not the time for that
she should be ashamed of herself the
administrator of the environmental
protection agency who says
his staff are in touch with local
partners on the ground and surf side
isn't ready to weigh in on a possible
climate connection
yet do you agree with that energy
secretary granholm that it's possible to
serve side
condos collapse may be a result of
climate change
you know i don't know if we have enough
information at this point
president biden is still trying to
address climate change the ways that he
can a few minutes ago he signed into law
a bill that limits methane emissions
at the end of that bill signing i
shouted out to ask him if he has any
kind of reaction to donald rumsfeld's
passing
and he didn't answer so the president
still has not addressed that on camera
or
off camera brett peter ducey live in the
north lawn peter thanks